stephen lawrence was murdered because he
was black
few crimes in recent times have had such
a profound or long-lasting impact
injustice watershed landmark are all
used to describe the lawrence case
the thing that makes lawrence
particularly important
and why i think the stephen lawrence
case is the case that is
apparently changed the nation is because
it hinges on something else
so the the murder itself was just
jaw-dropping and nobody could grasp that
but what followed was just beyond
anybody's imagination
[Music]
i remember the stephen dance case very
well it was the day before uh
my daughter's birthday so it was the
22nd of april 1993 and i remember i
remember it extremely well
it's hard to it's hard to describe it in
any other way as
just almost sport um i suspect i suspect
for an american audience you would be
able to
really relate to this and perhaps this
is why it was so shocking
because although we it wasn't in any
sense i kind of you know
us down south mississippi lynching it
wasn't far off
this is the bus stop where stephen
lawrence was brutally stabbed to death
in a savage racial attack
today the bus stops being changed there
are even new benches
but it does nothing to diminish the fact
that this point
represents the very worst in british
race relations
you had two boys stephen and his friend
who were
at a bus stop in southeast london one
evening and
they were part of an
absolutely unprovoked attack
where one of the boys managed to escape
stephen sandley didn't
and five uh young white men
um murdered him and as we
discovered as the story unfolds and uh
the
the press and the media were able to get
behind the story of the
stephen's murderers um these people had
practiced
these kinds of assaults and killings in
their bedrooms and also it was just the
most extraordinary thing
um and it was the premeditated nature of
it that i think
people found so very very difficult
in the days following stephen's murder
the police received
several tip-offs and all sources pointed
to the same five suspects
brothers neil and jamie are court gary
dobson
luke knight and david norris their gang
were named
26 times as stephen lawrence's killers
in the hours following his murder
lawrence handed in her
own list of suspects only to see the
officer first fold it up
and then screw it into a ball in front
of her
the mets failure to respond to initial
reports
would prove to be the first in a string
of injustices against the lawrence
family
that spanned more than two decades
a couple of weeks later and still no
arrests
the lawrence family had a press
conference airing their frustrations
that not enough was being done to catch
the killers
two days later they met with nelson
mandela
nelson mandela paused on a visit to
britain to publicly shake the lawrence's
hands
in private they talked he listened when
no one in authority would
we are very used to this type of thing
where life
is regarded as cheap in south africa
and but nevertheless it's a sense of
disconcert
that should happen in a country like
britain
so we had these two huge problems we had
this issue with a young man in a
london street who could be murdered but
in a dif in addition to the murder
uh we were confronted with this
extraordinary notion
of the ineptitude of the
police inquiry that was motivated
by race it's a racist society
that it doesn't matter um as for a black
person that is
it doesn't matter what standard of life
you try to achieve for yourself
it makes no difference in cases like
this you are treated as if you're
criminal right from the start
in 1994 a year after the murder covert
video
filmed by the police over several days
in one of the suspect's apartments
showed the gang using knives and making
violent
racist remarks
with the investigation going nowhere and
a growing sense
that the system had failed them
stephen's parents took matters into
their own hands
in 1996 doreen and neville lawrence took
out a private prosecution
against three suspects this was the
first
private prosecution for murder in the uk
for more than a century
but the lawrence's would once again
leave without justice
the judge directed the jury to return
not guilty verdicts
identification evidence was ruled
inadmissible and there was not enough
other evidence
to justify the prosecution three
suspects were acquitted
and the entering of not guilty verdicts
meant
they could not be tried again i think
one of the things that makes the racism
argument
such an interesting one is that there is
a there is the difference i think
between individual racism and
institutional racism
so and i think that um most people would
be
asked of the idea of being accused of
being racist
uh but because we live so comfortably in
a racist system
it's difficult to reconcile those two
points because self-evidently the system
is racist
in 1997 the lawrence family registered a
formal complaint with the police
complaints authority about the mets
handling of the investigation
soon after the daily mail and national
newspaper
ran a front page accusing the men of
killing lawrence
and challenging them to sue for liable
i think that i think the daily mail's
involved was really very surprising
if you think about the daily mail the
daily mail is sort of fox news of the
uk broadcasting environment and this was
very much a cnn story if you'd like if i
can put it that way for you
and the fact that it was actually fox
news in the form of a daily mail but
went to bat on this and actually
published the
extraordinary headline murderers with a
picture of the
these young men was a massive stance
with growing interest around the case
from both the media
and the public pressure was on the newly
elected labour administration to take
action by the summer of 1997
the new home secretary jack straw met
with the lawrences
and soon after the home office announced
a judicial inquiry into the police's
handling of the case
this inquiry will have full powers to
compel the attendance of witnesses to
give evidence under oath
and if they fail to do so to punish them
as if it were a contempt of court
the inquiry led by retired high court
judge sir william mcpherson
sat for 59 days to hear evidence from 88
witnesses
and produced more than 100 000 pages of
documents
the heart of this inquiry is the
allegation from the lawrence's and their
lawyers
that racism permeated the police
investigation into stephen's death
and permeates the society in which it
happened so it's become a touchstone for
the black community
and the outcome could point to the
direction of the future of race
relations in britain
the gang came to give evidence at the
public hearing
having been told they will face
prosecution
otherwise a huge crowd gathered outside
the hearing
hoping to get a chance to see them take
the stance
at the inquest the five suspects refused
to answer questions
the inquest jury ruled stephen had been
unlawfully killed
in a completely unprovoked racist attack
tensions between the police the public
and the suspects reached boiling point
outside the court
the inquiry was adjourned for three
hours after police fired
cs gas on protesters
the men spat and hit out at the crowd
whilst police escorted them back to
their vehicles
in 1999 two years after the inquiry
began
macpherson made 70 recommendations and
delivered
a damning final verdict he
he concluded in his uh really landmark
uh report um that the metropolitan
police service
was indeed institutionally racist
these 70 kind of overarching
recommendations were presented to the
metropolitan police force
and the metropolitan police force um to
be honest
has been um having a very um
a very complicated time engaging with it
the chairman of the inquiries the
william mcpherson repeatedly challenged
the paul about widespread instinctive
racism within the force
but sepal continually rebutted that
suggestion
um i find it difficult after five years
for the commissioner to
still be saying that he felt that there
was no racism
or corruption involved in stephen's case
so if that wasn't racism and it wasn't
corruption i still hadn't given the
answer
as to why stephen's killers are still
walking free
the inquiry prompted some serious
changes within the police force
and led to the race relations amendment
act
in 2000 that strive to eliminate
discrimination
and promote racial equality but the
problem
of racism is
it's so deeply woven into
the fabric of our society that it is by
no means a simple thing to resolve
the inquiry may have shown light on
institutional racism
but it didn't bring the result the
lawrence family so
desperately wanted the conviction of
their son's murderers
in the 11 years since there have been
three murder investigations
two police reviews and a public inquiry
yet his killers
still remain free now the crown
prosecution service says it's unlikely
the case will ever be solved
but then in 2005 double jeopardy
the rule preventing suspects being tried
twice
for the same crime was scrapped
something macpherson had recommended in
his report six years earlier
but with no new evidence this offered
the lawrence family
little hope at every turn
uh the lawrence case makes history they
they literally challenged every step of
the way
and whatever obstacle was in the place
statute laura and so on and stuff
they just overturned it a tiny spot of
blood found on the collar of dobson's
jacket
has a one in a billion chance of not
belonging to stephen
other fibers from the dead teenager's
clothing were allegedly found on a
multi-coloured cardigan
using the latest forensic technology new
evidence was found during a
cold case review of lawrence's murder
the tied two of the previously acquitted
suspects to the case
in 2011 the trial of gary dobson and
david norris for lawrence's murder
begins in light of the new evidence
it took a long time for justice to ride
out in the lawrence case
doreen watched the many suspects in her
son's murder walk free from
courts and inquiries 19 years later only
two of them
have been convicted a failure she says
of politicians
as well as the police it was 19 years
later
19 years let me say that again before
dobson and norris
were in prison so there were two things
about that they're extraordinary
one is it took 19 years for them to be
found brought to
brought to court again and charged with
found guilty and to do is that
19 years later baroness lawrence was
still as resilient and as as as
committed to this as she was 19 years
previously
we pay tribute to mr and mrs lawrence's
courage
and dignity they have contributed to
major changes within policing
the law and indeed within society
as a whole dorian lawrence continued to
campaign for justice for her son
as well as for other victims of racist
crime
in 2013 doreen was awarded the title of
baroness
for her relentless work within the
community
[Music]
she has been um you know
really really really uh embedded in this
psyche of this nation because of the
work that she's done and the sacrifice
she's paid
it it's hard to explain it in terms of
what it looks like but it was it was
yeah in in a way it was our own it was
our
probably the most important criminal
justice struggle
in terms of the black story in this
country in the last
however many years
policing has long been a focal point for
concerns over racial injustice in the uk
and despite changes sparked by the
lawrence case
and the landmark macpherson inquiry
black people
and ethnic minorities in britain are
still disproportionately represented
when it comes to police checks
imprisonment and deaths in custody
we need to remember that the uk is not
innocent we are a physical
representation
of our support for george floyd we are a
physical representation
of our support for stephen lawrence
i think there is a very challenging
conversation to be had about race and a
challenging conversation have about
racism
i think there is enough evidence to
suggest
that racism is
a is in is in the dna
of this nation